hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
different classifications of matter but
before we get to the different types of
matter let's talk about what matter is
matter is what makes up everything
around you it is defined as anything
that has mass and occupies space now
broadly matter can be broken down into
two different subdivisions these are
pure substances things that have a fix
or definite composition and mixtures
things that are made up of two or more
substances that are physically combined
but not chemically combined first let's
talk about pure substances which can be
further subdivided into two types
elements and compounds elements are made
up of one type of atom so these are
things I'm sure you've heard of things
like gold silver hydrogen helium sodium
fluorine oxygen chlorine titanium these
are all examples of elements everything
that you see on the periodic table is an
element compounds on the other hand are
things that are made of two types of
atoms in the same proportion also notice
that two types of atoms are the minimum
so it can be more than two types of
atoms that make up a compound so for
example when we think of compounds we
think of things like water h2o hydrogen
peroxide which is h2o to carbon dioxide
which is
co2 sodium chloride which is NaCl these
are all examples of compounds that are
made up of two or more types of atoms in
the same proportion that is every single
water molecule has two hydrogen's and
one oxygen every single molecule of
hydrogen peroxide has two hydrogen's and
two oxygens and so the components that
are making up these compounds note that
these are elements so for example
hydrogen oxygen carbon sodium chlorine
these are all elements that make up
compounds now let's go back to talking
about mixtures remember that mixtures
are made of two or more pure substances
that have been physically combined but
aren't they're not chemically combined
there aren't chemical bonds between the
individual components they can be
subdivided further into homogeneous
mixtures or heterogeneous mixtures
homogeneous or homogeneous mixtures have
a uniform composition this includes
things like the saline solution that you
may put your contacts in at night also
things like the air that we breathe so
saline solution is made of sodium
chloride and water but in a uniform
composition this means that the sodium
chloride is dissolved in the water and
just in looking at the saline solution
you cannot distinguish those two
different components it all looks like
an even mixture air is the same way we
can't see air but it's an even mixture
of several different gases things like
oxygen nitrogen carbon dioxide argon etc
these all make up the air that we are
always inhaling heterogeneous mixtures
are those
to have a variable composition this
means that it is a mixture of two
different substances but if you look at
the mixture you can see the different
substances one of the best examples is
oil and water so if you mix oil and
water together they tend to clump into
bits of oil or water they don't want to
mix very evenly and so they make up a
heterogeneous mixture when forced
together another example of a
heterogeneous mixture is salt water so
for example here when I say salt water
I'm talking about
like sea water so water in the ocean if
you take a cupful of water from the
ocean from the beach it's going to
contain water it's going to contain sand
it's going to contain different kinds of
salts different kinds of debris broken
up shells etc and you can hold it up to
the light and see all of the particulate
matter mixed in with the water and so
being able to see all of those
particulates in the ocean water is what
makes it a heterogeneous mixture so that
is it for the different ways to classify
matter I hope you learned a lot and
thanks for watching biology professor